common beijos and Nina yan of Berlin are
two of snapchats 200 million active
monthly users they sent video and photo
messages known in the lingo as snaps to
their friends they like snapchats many
photo editing tools but what makes the
app special is that recipients can see
the snaps for at most 10 seconds before
they self-destruct as if I use it to
show my friends where I am who I'm with
and what I'm doing vassi scott maka
families are full of southern month
they'll send a lot of embarrassing
photos over snapchat because they
disappear after a few seconds with some
50,000 followers Guyer ova patterson of
norway is one of europe's best known
snap chatters he compiles what snapchat
called stories another of the apps
features in a story images and videos
are compiled into a single stream
stories remain available for one day I
really love about snapchat is it's
really direct you're showing yourself
and you can share your daily stories the
stories can either last for 10 seconds
or for 24 hours and that's really the
beauty of it you should yeah you share
moments I would say two years ago
Peterson tested snapchat for his art
project called random people he took
snapshots of unsuspecting people out and
about in Christian sad then he used
doodles to obscure their identities and
place them into new contexts his fans
loved it and so did international
corporations it's a new form of
marketing the graphics designer began
producing snaps for the American
starbucks coffee chain and for Walt
Disney World
the people that follow you they trust
you they want to see what you can
deliver and I think that's what
companies are realized now that it's a
better way to reach an audience that's
appealing to businesses to so far only a
few German companies are in on the act
including sixth prospective customers
can use it to take a rental car on a
virtual test-drive sixth head of social
media Matthias truck says it's excellent
advertising it's good kinda plain convey
it has no distractions like Facebook's
newsfeed which shows all sorts of other
content or TV where people do other
things during the commercial breaks on
snapchat user attention is focused only
on your content you don't get that
anywhere else news facebook has also
spotted the potential in 2013 the social
network offered to buy snapchat for some
2.7 billion euros and was turned down
now snapchat is valued at nearly five
times that amount these days Peterson
can make a living off snapchat his
followers have turned into friends it's
open to interact with fans it's so fun
to create content it's probably one of
the best jobs I ever had that's good
news for guy over Patersons followers
who are always happy to see more snaps
from christian sand
you